i'm here with jersey kalinowski and
we're talking about the younger
investment plan Jersey thanks for
talking to us this afternoon let's start
by can you explain a little bit about
the investment plan what it's all about
thank you for this question the uncle
investment plan is related to the
jadorr'a digital agenda for europe no
our beautiful in European Commission
just define the target to build up in
Europe very high speed broadband
infrastructure assuming that fifty
percent of the households will have the
access to the broadband services with
the speed of 100 megabits per second in
year two thousand and the key question
is how to build this infrastructure and
the uncle plan is about defining the
areas where the european commission
would support the development
infrastructure and clearly
telecommunications one of the primary
areas and now the critical question is
how to utilize this model yes can it be
done can it be done do you think this is
the time you know if you have money you
can always spend them I think that the
major challenges that there is no
solution that one size fits all for all
the countries in the European Union
there's a different situation they okay
then you have Poland Romania Swiss or
the Netherlands each country is
different each the geo type that means
how households are distributed what is
the terrain is different that means the
unit cap expel connecting one subscriber
via fiber is different then you have
different market situation different
competition
I got the economics of this business
this is a different airport they are
poor in Western European countries could
be three times bigger larger than in
send a sentence in Europe that means
from the economic point of view it's a
big challenge to design the solution
meeting the needs of everybody yes so
what you're saying is really we need to
look at each country's situation and see
how we can make that work to deliver
against the plan yes that's my opinion
this is an inevitable face that each
country will have to design a specific
model for utilizing you know yo money
the model which will define i would say
how this monies will be spent that means
that what will be the special project
vehicles for the investment including
such decision criteria were they would
like to build up the infrastructure
kaveri only white spot in selected areas
all invest into the country wide
deployment of the access infrastructure
well it's going to be a very interesting
time we have ahead of us thanks for just
outlining that to us and to for speaking
to us today thank you thank you so very
interesting perspective there on the
younger investment plan